[Music]
Angie Tribeca what I love about the show
is that you guys pretty much the ethic
is let's just be really funny yeah and
so there's no shame and and you have all
kinds of crazy great gags in the show
and I would think it'd be a lot of fun
to work on it is I mean it's it's so
dumb and that's okay with us like that
so that's a good thing like a dumber we
are the better right and it is fun to
work on but it's really technical
because there'll be a scene where I'm
like I have like a crossbow like in my
pants and then I have like like a like
an animal trainer here who's like
waiting to hand me an animal for like a
visual gag right and you know we we just
have like a lot of silliness around us
so it's our job to not break you have
what I love is that you have and one of
my favorite things about the show is
that you have a co-worker who's a dog
but you don't reference the fact that
he's a dog at all detective David
Hoffman detective detective David
Hoffman is a dog and there was never any
and I love that and there's never any
even a sly reference to the fact that
he's a dog how do you get through a
scene with that dog that's a little
tough for me that's a little tough for
me because we'll be in the middle of
like a serious like pushing the mystery
forward scene and I'll look back and
there's like a dog with like sunglasses
on the phone replying to an email with
fake dog puppet yeah I hope yeah it's
it's pretty it's pretty hard like the
dog is person is pretty hard now I would
think because you're on TBS they do us
allow us to say four-letter words from
time to time I know that must be a
little liberating it's awesome we can do
it on this show - yeah sure yeah yeah I
can say no I should have wore no no
there goes my Strauss for an immediate
dismissal no yes yes that's one that's
when they'll take away from your show
right yeah yeah well that's the thing is
you only get a couple per episode there
are only there are only so many on TBS
that get passed around right so now you
using these right now
anymore your hair oh really it makes the
hair wobble yeah yeah so I would think
yeah so you you get to say them
occasionally on TBS and that was B field
Street cuz you certainly couldn't do
that on Parkson no no no and we
definitely we're very appreciative of it
and because we only get a couple per
episode there's a little we have to be
very concerning with her you're very
reverent about them you take them out of
like a mahogany box from 1959 are you a
fan of cop shows did you grow up loving
waking cop shows because your show is
such a great spoof of procedurals yeah I
did I definitely I definitely love law
and order I think it's like hard not to
love it you could be like not for me but
you're not very gonna be like I hate law
and order no can't know the show is
engrossing it's all-encompassing and
engrossing but I was like the only
person when I lived in New York my first
audition in New York was for Law & Order
and I never booked an episode you never
got an order everybody did a lot that's
it's a real rate of passage and that's a
badge of shame for you
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you